Bipolar disorder can have lots of effect
on a person's day to day functioning.
Um,
so for instance,
again in the middle of an episode of
either mania or depression,
um,
people who are manic will often do
things that are really impulsive and
really out of character.
And so issues of infidelity can come up.
For instance,
in a patient with media who's having a
sexual partner or sexual partners
outside of it,
the relationship in the midst of a manic
episode,
people will often spend money that they
really can't afford to spend in the
midst of a manic episode,
which you can imagine will cause a lot
of strain for them personally.
But also,
um,
in the context,
in the context of their families,
people in the midst of,
um,
mania often don't appear to be logical
and so they will go to work and we'll
have lots of irritability.
And you can imagine again that um,
coworkers are confused,
bosses are confused and especially if
they don't understand a lot about the
illness,
it can affect their work relationships
and their ability to maintain their
employment.
Um,
you can imagine that if it's hard to get
up out of bed and even go to the
supermarket and get your groceries for
the day,
that it can be very difficult to go to
work,
um,
and get all the things that you need to
get done either in your work life or
again,
or in your personal life.
People were port guilt or sometimes
feeling like they're worthless.
Um,
people will also report that they feel
like they're either kind of moving in
slow motion,
which is known as psychomotor
retardation and occasionally people will
report that they actually feel jittery,
which is known as psychomotor agitation.
Um,
in addition,
people report disturbances in their
sleep.
What's your most commonly,
um,
insomnia?
So either difficulty falling asleep,
waking up in the middle of the night or
waking up earlier in the morning.
Then one intends to occasionally,
this can be hypersomnia though where
people are sleeping,
for instance,
10,
12,
13,
14 or more hours per day.
Patients with bipolar disorder often,
um,
are resistant to receiving treatment,
especially during a manic episode.
And this is really part of the illness
in terms of not understanding that one
is sick,
bipolar disorder cannot be cured.
However,
people will often find that they will go
the,
you know,
periods of time without having any
illness or periods of euthymia.
It really depends on the individual and
how their clinical course goes,
as well as finding treatments that work
the mainstay of treatments or mood
stabilizers.
So these are moods,
medications that are used to keep
somebody from having most notably,
uh,
you know,
a manic episode or a depressive episode.
Finding the right treatment can
sometimes be a little frustrating.
Um,
and patients really need to hang in
there as their doctors tried different
medications to figure out what works
best with their neurobiology in order to
support a loved one who has bipolar
disorder,
it's really important to realize that
this is an like any other illness.
A lot of times people will think of
mental illnesses as being something
that's within the control of the
individual.
And the individual will often think that
as well,
feeling tremendous guilt when they do
have episodes of either mania or
depression.
And so the first thing is realizing
that,
um,
people don't choose to have bipolar
disorder and they would definitely
choose that,
um,
live with more mental wellness than
having this illness.
Um,
it's really important to be calm,
present and consistent with people with
bipolar disorder as well as supporting
them and maintaining their treatment in
the next 10,
20,
30,
50 years.
I really see a lot more research being
done to try to find treatments that are
effective and have less side effects
than some of the medications that we
have currently available today.
I really only see better things for the
future.